you can't take this guy anywhere nope
you can't take this guy anyway rip some
Elvis ever I go
that was yesterday and now Miley Cyrus
is home from the hospital after a case
of tonsillitis she posted this pic to
her Instagram story and yeah Cody is
totally shirtless quote she made it home
recovering from surgery send all the
vibes and Cody posted these shots here
writing we are four and on this one
quote my sick girl finally free this all
comes after Miley called Cody her bf he
showed up to visit her in the hospital
guitar and roses in hand oh yeah
and he wrote a song for Miley
[Music]
she's definitely like a very like at
heart a very very sweet normal like go
for Nashville like and we were spending
hang out at her ranch in Nashville and
she's just like I'm just like a lot of
people say these things like that you
know she's just like the coolest Jake
now we still don't know just how serious
things are but we do know they go way
back and one guy who is very into this
pair his chest and Bieber he commented
on this shot of Cody yeah Cody shirtless
again and simply said double date to
which Cody replied with a simple text me
now this actually makes a lot of sense
of course Cody and Justin also go way
back it'll definitely give them a hard
rock you know there's certain people in
the media that that people like pick on
you know like for me for me I personally
just try to like kind of take a little
step back and and try not to cause any
drama or anything but you know this I
feel like people kind of like to hone in
on on certain certain people like the
like Bieber the guys have also released
music together remember 2015's home to
mama
[Music]
talk to me about what you're like in the
studio solo versus what you're like in
the studio with Justin Bieber by myself
like it's it's stuff I think it's more
of like a carefree process and you kind
of get to do what's coming out of your
own your own mind then you know I have a
producer that is kind of helps you craft
it when you're working with another
artist especially like Justin who
definitely has like many like different
different influences on his and like a
different you know style of music that
that that he is his the part that he's
going down like it's it's very cool but
sometimes you bought heads a little bit
but but I'm at the end of the day like
usually when you take those kind of
chances to collaborate and to bring two
worlds together almost it's like okay
you come up with something really cool
here and it usually it turns out even
better than you expected and that
kind of what happened with with debbie
and i so here's hoping that we see
photos of Justin and Ailee hanging out
with Kody and Miley anyways for all the
latest on these couples stick with all
things et we will be sure to keep you
updated until next time I'm Katie Krause
and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]